um let's talk about the ipos that are
going on it's
been pretty amazing to see
the world we grew up in over the last
decade where nobody would go public
airbnb and uber taking their time taking
their time
yuri milner and everybody else throwing
late stage money don't go public
and then lo and behold my bestie chamoth
and now reed hoffman and mark pinkus and
everybody else is doing specs
and now there is a way to get public
quicker
you did open door right and was that
with chamath or yeah
chamath and adam bain um
really worked on bringing open door into
their spac
which you know is a transaction that
hasn't technically closed but you can
you know sort of see the market cap
um you know because you can buy a
character holding yeah ipob
um it'll it should close hopefully next
week um
and it's been a very successful um
experience both working with smoth and
adam and then be just a public market
reaction
i think as of today we're probably
valued at like
13 14 billion um so chamoth got a great
deal at five
yeah and and when you go through this
process
um i don't want to talk specifically
about anything that will get you in
trouble but just talking about the spac
process putting aside uh
open doors process just spacks in
general
uh keep you out of trouble um make sure
you don't disclose anyone you're not
supposed to but
tell us about the process and
the window of companies that it's best
suited for
rather than a direct listing like say um
spotify did or waiting like uber and
airbnb did like waiting 11 years so let
me start with first principle first
principle is i think waiting was always
terrible advice is one of the worst
pieces of advice that anybody in silicon
valley has given for the last 15 years
and you know fortunately some of the
companies i've been involved in didn't
listen to that advice
i think realistically only bill gurley
and me
were like sitting publicly critiquing
the people
dispensing this advice i i believe
strongly that companies should go public
as
almost as fast as possible i wrote a
whole chapter in
in a book that i highly recommend the
founders called high growth handbook
published by eli gill um the whole
entire chapter is why to go public why
to go public as fast as possible
and why everybody doesn't do that it's
like really sacrificing their company's
potential
um but that was a controversial view
fortunately in the last
six months it's become a very
conventional view spax are a process
uh really for companies that
uh suddenly realized that keith and bill
gurley were right and hadn't really
prepared for traditional ipo whether
in ipo or direct listing and they wanted
to accelerate the process
and find a way to do that a spot can be
a good vehicle to accelerate the process
where the management team hadn't really
prepared properly that isn't the really
best feature of a spock truthfully the
best feature of a spec at the end of the
day
is that legally for a a hardcore
technology company
that's really innovating on a deeply
technological
solution they can guide um
years into the future about the revenue
potential of the business
whereas through an s-1 process or a
traditional ipo process
it's extremely legally precarious
virtually impossible
to guide future years revenue and so as
a result of that
if you have a breakthrough technology
that will have a market
it's much better in many ways to be able
to
convince and articulate the market size
to potential investors through a spac
process than you would able to be able
to do
in a traditional ipo now that said it's
not that different than a private
fundraising people have always done this
in private fundraisings
so when people pitch us at founders fund
even when they're you know reinventing a
rocket or reinventing manufacturing in
space reinventing genetic sequencing
they're they're talking about the
revenue potential in the slides in the
presentation
so this is very similar to what you'd
see in a private fundraising process
it's just now possible to do it publicly